all right welcome to the future of Life
Institute podcast I'm here with Leonard
Heim Leonard could you please introduce
yourself sure yeah thanks for having me
um as you said my name is Leonard Heim
I'm a researcher at the center for the
governance of AI in short Goff AI that
we'll usually say
um coffee guy's mission is like roughly
we're trying to build like a Global
Research Community where we're trying to
help Humanity to navigate this
transition to Advanced AI I think the
thing which might have seen over the
last few weeks and what I'm mostly doing
I'm working on this research stream
which we call compute governance so I'm
thinking about computational
infrastructure I'm particularly
interested just like is computer
promising not of AI governance what are
like the sub nodes of compute we can use
to achieve beneficial AI outcomes what
are Hardware mechanisms we can use to
support this regimes so like everything
compute in general but over time this
became more narrow my background is in
Hardware engineering so I studied
Computer Engineering in school
spend a lot of time actually figuring
out how computers work and now I'm
trying to build on top of this knowledge
trying to yeah use compute to steer
towards more beneficial outcomes
fantastic all right so what I imagine I
was talking about here is how we can
forecast AI progress specifically by
looking at at compute but perhaps I mean
before we get there we should probably
introduce the key factors that's driving
AI progress which you call the AI Triad
and what what is the AI Triad and and
what are the factors involved here AI
trying out three factors I think another
way how to think about this I think is
which I sometimes user concept is we can
also call it the AI production function
you know it's a function where we have
certain inputs and we have certain
outputs and questions like what are
these inputs and one way how to think
about the inputs is like to split it up
into three components which we describe
as algorithms data and compute what do
you mean with algorithms well when we
think about AI nowadays we mostly talk
about machine learning within machine
learning we talk about deep learning and
even within there you can go too deeper
to like the specifics of these
algorithms be it the Transformer
architectures how do you train these
systems all these kinds of things
they're all important for dimensional
output the next thing is the data right
those systems as we do machine learning
we have some kind of learning so we give
them some data on which you should learn
on
um this is nowadays like big data sets
via text be it images whatever we're
training these systems on which is
another input right and lastly then we
have the factor which actually enables
all of this which is compute or
computational infrastructure
um this is eventually the system this
physical infrastructure we need to then
train these systems and also later like
to execute them
um sometimes people also think about
Talent as another Factor there I usually
would describe it as a secondary input
you know Talent helps with better
algorithms maybe crying more data maybe
making compute better but like if you
think about like yeah those three are
like fundamental to like break them down
and think about like
how much they made for AI progress what
is the output there and how have they
developed over time does it make sense
to separate these factors and talk about
how much each factor contributes to AI
progress or is it simply so interrelated
that it doesn't make sense to to
separate uh separate them out like that
yeah that's definitely an ongoing
question I think it makes sense trying
to separate them right I'm like I'm
claiming I do compute governance and I
think maybe in the future people will be
claiming they do algorithm governance or
data governance and again there are
always downsides to put things into
boxes but sometimes like some apps like
having these kinds of models yeah if we
try to separate them I think what I've
been historically interested in just
like well what was their historic role
over time and I think in general we can
say they all trade off with each other
right if I want to build an AI system I
can just like try to spend a lot of
times figuring out the better algorithms
getting more data or just like throwing
more compute at the problem and
eventually will turn out to be like a
better AI system with better
capabilities
um what we've seen over time with with
data is we just acquire more over time
so roughly it doubled I think it was
every one 1.4 years so the amount of
data we used I think this 1.4 years was
not for text Data this again would look
different for image data for voice
models but I think Text data is the
thing we're currently thinking about
when we talk about large language models
whereas in contrast if we think about
compute what I mean here is like the
compute used for training these systems
right and when I say how much compute we
use for training the systems I refer to
how many floating Point operations feel
needed to train the system that it's
eventually finished and it can be run we
did an analysis on this and we roughly
saw that the training compute is
doubling every six months so this this
is like faster progress like faster
doubling compared to data and how is
this a doubling rate evolved over time
so so as compute always been been
doubling every six months or as it has
the rate of doubling also increased over
time yeah like when we like we did this
investigation on compute the first ones
to do it was like actually an old man it
had a blog post called a and compute
they did this I think in 2018 19
something on these lines and what they
found well this AI training computer has
been doubling every 3.4 months so twice
as fast as I just said so we did we ran
the same analysis with just like way
more ml systems at the beginning of 2022
added somewhere new systems like well if
we now look at the trend it's actually
just doubling every every six months and
this is partially they picked like a
cutoff point where just like new systems
like pretty compute intensive systems
like Alpha go and these kinds of systems
came out which yeah were like really at
the top of the Strand and like skewed
the solid Trend upwards I think if we
would like look at the data right now
which everybody can do if you just go to
epochai.org
um I think the doubling time would sit
somewhere Point 6.5 months or seven
months right now we don't haven't added
g54 yet because nobody told us yet how
much computers is if we could achieve
before we might have better insights
there okay so if we were to put some
numbers on it how much of AI progress
would you say is attributable to compute
yeah I I don't feel like I I would like
to put numbers on maybe maybe we can
describe it with like what Richard
Sutton calls This Bitter lesson where he
was saying like oh people have been
trying to develop new fancy algorithms
trying to learn from the brain but what
we've just historically seen over the
last years basically we just have like
search algorithms and we just throw more
computed right and like of course I mean
you're talking to a guy who claims he's
doing compute governance so I think it's
like an important note am I not saying
like oh 50 of the progress of AI is due
to compute or it's 90 I can't tell there
might be more analysis on the Futures
that's up for the economists I'm saying
seems like an important note I think it
has some unique properties independent
of how important it is for AI it has
some unique properties which you can use
to yeah achieve better and beneficial
outcomes I think it's important for us
to talk a little bit about how modern
advanced chips are produced so perhaps
you could talk about you know where are
they produced how how difficult this is
to produce these chips and who are the
key players involved and so on yeah I
think I think the disclaimer is year I
think chips or integrated circuits are
probably the most complex device product
whatever we as humankind have ever
produced so whatever I say here take a
finger grain of salt I'm like trying to
explain on like a really high
abstraction layer this is basically an
effort of humankind that we have these
kinds of chips it's a global supply
chain what is one way of thinking about
it I think it's like useful to think
about like free processors we can say
that's like the design phase so you just
think about like well how do we actually
we have all of these transistors we put
them somewhere how do we how do we put
them that it actually does some Marv
right I think that's like
constructionally which most people
actually do not get like us talking
right now here everybody having a
smartphone just relies on a device which
is like switches and you have trillions
or billions on them on a chip so that's
the design phase who are people who
design these chips Apple for example is
designing ships they're just like hey
here's our new M1 a17 whatever they put
in their MacBooks or iPhones
once they've designed such a chip this
is just like some piece of code like
eventually it goes down to like how this
shift eventually looks like
um we need to fabricate this chip right
um this is where we then etch this chip
years of history there how this has been
done I think the important actors to
know here is like tsmc Samsung and Intel
those are the ones which are leading the
cutting-edge chip production and an
important another factor is there
there's the company called asml which
people might have heard about is this
obscure company sitting in the
Netherlands which sells the machines to
tsmc Intel and Samsung which then
produces these chips right then we get
our chips out of it and the last thing
we need to do is like we need to
assemble this chip we test and package
them this is sometimes done at another
provider or it's directly done at the
fap right so the important thing is like
apple sells these shirts but they're not
actually producing them they just think
about how to design them and then you
send it off elsewhere right it's kind of
if if you guys think about like oh I'm
printing a t-shirt for my local
um I don't know football club you're not
going to produce it you're going to send
it up to this our person who's like
producing a bunch of t-shirts and then I
print your T-shirt with your local thing
that's the same as apple is doing it and
then eventually you get it back and then
you sell these so like yeah the free
steps um designing fabrication and
lastly assembly testing manufacturing
that's the chip supply chain and what
about certain bottlenecks in in these
Supply chains what would happen for
example if asml cease to exist or the
tsmc sees to exist how much depends on
specific companies here as I just said
it's a really complex product it's the
effort of like all of
all of us all of the whole world coming
together so it's a global supply chain
right
um I think there's explicit examples of
ASMR and tsmc are interesting so if we
look at asml as almost the only company
in the world which is producing is eov
machines which are used for producing
Cutting Edge chips so if asml sees to
exist I think they're going to be like a
big shortage and like we're going to
take a probably gonna hit a recession or
something along these lines right I mean
we can continue using a machine say
currently chip but we want to keep on
going right that's like the history of
computing just keep on pushing making
this ship smaller smaller and smaller
over time asml is the strongest case we
literally just have one company who's
producing these UV machines right but
even if they move to the fabrication
where we have asml Intel and Samsung for
cutting egg chips tsmc makes right
roughly 70 to 80 of the whole Revenue in
this domain so tsmc is like a really
important actor layer right which is
producing all of these chips like all of
our iPhones
um and MacBooks and whatever kinds of
chips we are using this might look
different for chips which are sitting in
your I don't know in your dishwasher or
in your car these are usually like older
note chips which I use so they wouldn't
be hit by a semi directly but I mean as
someone starts producing the water chips
so we have what people call bottlenecks
or as other people call it also choke
points right which I guess we're going
to be talking about later at some point
which you can then use to achieve um
certain goals yeah I think that's like
roughly the bottlenecks I'm just like
it's just really complicated producer it
just costs a lot of money it has a
limited number of apps and it's just
really really really hard to use these
kinds of chips so the stories I've heard
um about yeah how hard this reduces
chips which kind of like obscure things
happened which would use the yield like
how many good chips you get out of this
yeah it's crazy how far are the nearest
competitors behind the the very Cutting
Edge companies here and like Intel might
be like the interesting case to look at
right like who was once leading this and
then got overtaken by tsmc into the was
this company who designed the chips and
also produced them and also package them
right they were like doing this across
the whole thing whereas like at some
point AMD came along to something like
revolutionizer was like hey we actually
just designed the chips and somebody
else is going to be producing them how
much behind are there I mean I just said
like a tsmc makes up the majority of the
share of these Cutting Edge chips and
tsmc is just leading the field there
there are some forecasting questions and
it looks like there's tsmc and Samsung
are going to be achieving three
nanometers this year will start Mass
producing this Intel probably won't
achieve this but probably next year so I
guess Intel is like one year behind but
that just describes the the node right
the transistor size so like the
fabrication process it does not describe
how much they actually produced I think
there's still a big difference there
like this materials like way more apps
to Just Produce way more for usml I
guess it's more trickier um I guess a
bunch of the other competitors just kind
of gave up and they're just hoping like
well we can might not be able to produce
Erie machines but maybe we can make the
next thing after the UV machines right
um I haven't seen good analysis there
like how far the albums are behind I
guess it's just fair to say it's just
really really hard and we have like
certain countries so like trying really
really hard right now to produce these
kinds of machines to produce the chips
but also like the Fabs which produce the
chips and I guess it will be hard for
them up to maybe impossible if there's
like not new paradigms coming along it's
an interesting difference between
between computer chips in general and
the
Cutting Edge computer chips used for
specifically AI purposes and in terms of
production and supply chain or is it
simply the same companies leading both
chips in general and AI specific chips I
think it's it's useful to to think again
about like our free steps we have the
design we have the fabrication and the
packaging the design companies are
different for AI chips at least if we
think about which AI chips I mostly
think about when I think about AI
governance right so I think about AI
chips ending up in data centers AI
accelerators mostly produced by Nvidia
but for example the a100 h100 our names
referred there but also Google with
their tpus their tensor processing units
but you only keep in-house so they are
designing them right there's some like
equivalent to Apple Apple also is like
AI core processors on their smartphone
chip on a laptop but those are not the
chips which I'm talking about when we
talk about like Training large-scale
Systems when we talk about training gpt4
you're not using your smartphone you're
not using your computer there there's a
different
so the design space is different but
actually the fabrication phase is the
same they both send it off to eventually
to tsmc or any other and they're going
to be then producing it for you
um and the same goes for the packaging
process so if we talk about cutting edge
of the talk about chips like Yip they
have like the three nanometer chips
they're sitting in your smartphone
they're sitting in your laptop but
they're also sitting in like these AI
accelerators for example gpus which then
go to the data centers the difference is
design first there right the chips are
like eventually turn out to be
physically different
um they Implement certain functions for
example like a smartphone is still a
general Processing Unit a CPU right it
can do a bunch of stuff whereas yai
accelerators we move along the Spectrum
more towards more specialized chip right
it's a specialized chip which is really
really good at solving parallel problems
what we've learned is that so Chip
production is extremely Advanced and
extremely complex and we've learned that
it plays a key role in in driving AI
progress so let's talk about what we can
learn if we try to extrapolate progress
in compute and find out what this can
tell us about progress in AI in general
so this is what you might refer to as AI
timeline forecasting just thinking about
based on what we know about compute
about data about algorithms
when might we expect for example uh
artificial general intelligence to arise
what can we what can we say specifically
based on thinking about compute here so
it's like a question which many people
are thinking about just like well when
is this this artificial general
intelligence transformative intelligence
human level whatever you name it right
and I think there we already go into the
details of things like really important
for people to actually say what they
mean with these kinds of terms
um and not just say like oh my AGI
timelines are XYZ
independent of that some reports are
trying to operationalize this and trying
to forecast this and figure out when
this has happened right and compute just
plays an important role there I just try
to describe the AI production function
and I was like well we have these inputs
then we have like to say a production
function and we get certain outputs and
I'm asking when is this output in AGI
what does this mean about my inputs
right and I think they're like two
famous apprents there's ways of like
trying to do about it I think one of
them is like actually from igr code
which is this biological anchors report
which ones I think on this podcast here
before and this is actually also
something like a compute Centric
framework where she's actively asking us
like well if I would need to rerun
Evolution how much compute is this how
much floating Point operations is this
if I need to read run the title
development how much compute is this so
we have like these different compute
Milestones right and what she then tries
to do as the next step is like we have
this compute Milestones we're like well
if I have a deep learning model which
roughly uses Edgemont compute as these
Milestones it might have similar
capabilities right and then she actually
tries to forecast like compute available
in a given year and then you try to
figure out like well what is the price
performance of compute this is like
roughly looking to Moose law right how
many chips will be produced how many
flops can they calculate and then you
also look into how much you're actually
willing to spend right it's an important
question where it's like well do I
actually want to spend that much money
on doing this one training run to
achieve this certain Milestone and the
last thing is
um you need to adapt this to some type
of algorithmic efficiency right over
time you achieve you need less compute
to achieve the same capabilities right
so like you discount it over time this
is like what this described as
algorithmic efficiency that's one way of
thinking about it and that's one way how
compute and I compute forecasting feeds
directly into trying to forecast
transformative AI given that people use
different Opera different definitions of
for example human level AI or
transformative AI or artificial general
intelligence is is there something
useful we can gain from aggregating
predictions across a number of Reports
say that these reports use slow slightly
different definitions of what we're
trying to to predict will this introduce
too much noise for us to say something
useful I think I think it's still useful
to just like maybe look at them and just
see what different forecasts think we
should like uh like trying to think
about are they actually trying to
forecast the same and what are the
different biases in play there if I
think it's like hard to just throw
together a survey with this bio anchors
report right but if you have like two
empirical approaches be it the bioencies
report like maybe like another approach
um I think it's fair to just like Pro
like look at them right so something
where you do a survey of all the
different methods and then you can weigh
it to your own needs
um I think what I'm more interested in
is like actually well it's cool to have
like these these timelines you know when
is this thing going to happen or
something I'm excited about like the
Intermediate inputs to these kinds of
systems right if somebody is just like
thinking about AI timelines and that's
on a way to think about AI timelines
they figure out what is the growth of
compute this is important right just for
the things we've just discussed for
example there's a guy like me who looks
at growth computers like well this looks
interesting maybe you can do compute
governance maybe you can use this now to
eventually achieve something so you
figure out better timelines but you also
like also intermediate outputs which are
useful and this is part of the big
reason why I'm excited about AI
timelines research it's like there's a
bunch of intermediate inputs
um to these kinds of models which are
useful and again from empirical model
it's like the bio anchors report they
are way more of this intermediate input
compared to a survey in a survey I'm
like all I have is like maybe the
qualitative entry from like some
researcher but they tend to be big and
most of time to just get a number so I
don't know how what Credence to put on
this so in the process of trying to
forecast transformative AI we might
learn something that will turn out to be
super useful for us let's get your take
on this whole issue so based on all the
reports you've read based on you know
your deep dives into into compute how
would you think about uh when we might
expect artificial general intelligence
or transformative AI for what it's worth
I don't think there's like something
special about just like Leonard telling
his timelines or his numbers or
something thing I think it like really
depends
um more like the Intermediate inputs are
more interesting yeah how would I
disconnect my views on this I do think
there is a significant chance that AI
turns out to be a big deal you can
Define it as transformative AI is Agi or
something right I do think I have like a
50 chance like within the next 20 years
or so there might be something what we
might call an AGI or a transformative AI
right what do I mean by this well maybe
we can measured on benchmarks there's
like this famous mmau benchmarks like
yeah there's something which like scores
like 95 of this maybe this system would
also like pass like a really long
touring test but like somebody's like
really drilling down on these systems
and maybe the system also wins like a
MAF Olympiad and also the system is like
able to control a robot you know which
takes care of my dishwashers I think
it's like a typical example need so like
these are ways that we're trying to
operationalize this for example within
with an Epoch if you're trying to think
about forecasting our timelines like if
I try to take this approbialization it's
like yeah I guess within the next 20
years it's like a 50 percent chance
what's happening and then I have a
really long tail right if it's like not
happening soon I was like well I don't
know maybe there's like some magic sauce
to this so it just really yeah it just
will take a longer time we need to
reinvent like the the whole thing again
to eventually to get to AGI do you think
robotics is in the same category as more
cognitive labor performed by AI it seems
to me just looking at the landscape that
we're making amazing amazing we have
amazing developments in what you could
call cognitive tasks but less progress
in robotics so if if we Define find AGI
or transformative AI to include robotics
that might significantly delay our
prediction of when it will arrive it's
it's like actually part of the key thing
it's like man maybe maybe we have like
those really smart systems we can do a
lot of these things but like it just got
really bad hands right
um and me as as like active like the
regular engineer who did like some
robotics I was like it's really
disappointing how like how slow progress
is there it's still progress don't get
me wrong right if you look I think
everybody here watches like from Times
Like These Boston Dynamics videos right
you see those robots doing crazy stuff
but there's just like still moving
physical things our hands are like
pretty pretty good on a bunch of stuff
and it turns out this is really really
hard to get this on a computer so I'm
pretty confident there will be like
there might be right now a system which
knows how to clean up my dishwasher and
it might now have to really efficiently
but just like the sensitivity or like
the logistics of moving your hands fast
enough and like precise enough it's just
gonna be like a really hard thing I
actually think like robotics is like a
thing which people just sometimes anchor
on too much whether just think about
like oh AI is only dangerous if it if it
can move or has legs or something I was
like no actually our life is like so
digital anyways most of our critic
infrastructure is controlled by
Computing systems you don't need hands
to do a bunch of stuff right us having
this conversation right now has nothing
to do with us having physics hands this
could happen completely by us being AI
simulator in this whole conversation
being made up true true okay so how much
do you think robotics depends on compute
is there a is there a compute bottleneck
that's holding robotics back or is it
simply or not simply but is it is it
more about designing uh accurate hands
or accurate sensors or or something else
yeah I think I think it's mostly about
the letter so like funny enough like if
if I say like today's systems use more
more compute you also have the problem
like these systems are big right deep
learning big systems billions of
parameters if you want to run to run
them locally you sometimes can't because
they're just too big they're too
computation intensive so if I just put
like a Jeep D4 in a Boston Dynamics
reporter this thing is going to be out
of battery kind of kind of quickly
because you just need like four a100 to
like run the system at a speed which is
good enough so this will be seen like
from a papers on Google but it's like
yeah we had like this really small model
because yeah we couldn't use a bigger
model right and I guess sick most most
of the stuff still boils down to just
like how good are robotics hands these
kinds of stuff you would be good enough
at controlling it but you're simply not
sensitive enough and like precise enough
50 cents I do expect AI can help on this
just AI can accelerate research there
are some resources right now how to make
better robotic hands how to build better
robots in general they now use AI tools
to summarize their research or maybe the
items to bring some new ideas and maybe
new ideas come along maybe in the future
we even have ai systems which have like
completely new ideas how we will be
building robots right looks like
Evolution figured it out looks like
Evolution figured out good movement way
earlier than good brains right we could
walk before we I mean probably not
walking but at least crawl and like jump
from two to three before we could like
actually think really well so maybe we
have some reason to believe there's
actually not such a hard problem and
like I think I'm getting like a bit
confused why we haven't figured it out
yet maybe we have an option of
simulating physical environments and
learning how to do robotics in
simulation before deploying them and
that I think would would make our
robotics progress more dependent on
compute so if we could run huge
simulations these simulations would be
extremely computationally intensive but
that that is a possible path forward I
don't know whether that actually gets us
all the way there to real world robotic
interaction what do you think about this
dude do you have any insight here it
seems right definitely can help with
this I think we generally have this form
like like this Sim to reel just like
yeah like our simulations are complex
but you've seen reality of being more
complex and I guess this will just
continue being like some kind of barrier
um and like yeah I'm definitely excited
of people trying to think more about
this like how how would this actually
translate you know if I have this robot
moving in my simulation can I actually
actually also move in the world right
might be easier for your Roomba you know
just like driving around and taking it
only it's like a 2d space but like a
walking robot with legs seems way harder
yeah okay so we talked about the we
talked about the AI Triad of of data
algorithms and use and perhaps one
useful thing here is to talk about how
these can be traded off against each
other
um because this might tell us something
about how important compute is so what
do you think for example if we had the
perfect data set how much would this
mean in terms of AI progress combined
combine the perfect data set with the
compute and algorithms available today
yeah I would love to know the answer to
this just like what is the perfect data
set one thing we've yeah like ran into
when we like tried to collect just like
what are the data Trends how much we've
been using just like but actually the
different dimensions of data right I can
measure data like how many data points
how many totems how many pictures how
many gigabytes but we all know there's a
different quality in data right and now
we get into the tricky things like well
how do we measure quality right
um on these types of data
one thing how you can see just like the
data quality matters if you for example
I think it was a chinchilla paper which
is a paper by deepmind so you have a big
data of text right and then you train
the system on this text and usually it
only gets succeeded the text only once
it only has like one Epoch per text but
interesting enough for example for
um given chinchilla that it needed a lot
of data because they found new scaling
laws they actually did run twice about
the Wikipedia text I was like well
Wikipedia that's like a really great
text you know it's like really high
quality data it's like maybe closer to
the truth than just Reddit or like a
bunch of other stuff on the internet so
let's train the system twice on this
because it's better and we have like
good reasons to believe if we look at
humans that actually like data
efficiency can be way better I'm
claiming a more data efficient than gpd4
at least for the moment
um I don't need to I mean I haven't read
as much but you know and some things I
can maybe outpace gbd4
um so there's lots to gain there and if
you use less data
um this also means we have like smaller
training runs to some degree right
unless we just show the data way more
time so like it's it's not clear how it
directly translates but in general means
like more high quality data probably is
useful probably better than low quality
data I don't know how much better and
less data means also less compute for
these kinds of systems so I think
there's definitely progress to be made
over time and I think this is also
partially where we've seen where we've
seen progress over time right if you
just had better data when more beta data
became available so my impression is
that we are actually using something
close to all the data available online
to train the biggest models is that also
your impression do you think that's true
that we are we are reaching limits of
how much data we we have available
online
yeah um it's not like I think that's
more data so we try to look into this
and I try to be like well how much more
text data is out there and you you start
becoming a bit creative right like oh
like we we don't produce Text data right
now we produce voice data but guess what
we can run another AI system on this to
produce more text later cool I don't
think I don't think this podcast is is
the thing that should I mean maybe
that's the thing they should be training
on I don't know but there is YouTube out
there let's just take all the YouTube
videos in the world let's transcribe
them here we go we have way more text
this is high quality data probably not
most of it's just like probably not that
good some of it might be better right
like some pretty good podcasts out there
so there's like more data to be acquired
and we try to forecast this like how
much videos are getting produced if we
like transcribe then how much my data do
we get out of this and then we were like
thinking about like looking it's like
well it looks like at some point we
might run off data just not for the
simple reason there is lots of it out
there don't get me wrong but we're also
just using lots of it and we try to
predict the stem of like scaling laws
which is like this thing which describes
where we have a network of the size how
much data do we need and how much
compute do we need to train it like
pretty much optimal and it's unclear if
these scaling laws can continue to the
scale which we discovered there but
there's definitely a thing where you
might lack high quality data and I think
right now I think reinforcement learning
from Human feedback is already such an
example it's like actually quality
matters I think you know like this human
feedback is like actually way more
useful than training your on like a
bunch of Scrappy data on the internet so
I think I'm more interested in just like
there's more data out there but you want
to get high quality data how do you get
more high qualitator for the things you
actually care about for the things you
actually want to do yeah so when when
I've played around with tpt4 for example
is some of the some of the output text
is very clever and uh you we might be
attempted to use that output text to
train new language models
this sounds like some kind of Ponzi
scheme or some kind of magic where we
make up data out of thin air do you
think that would work do you think do
you think output from from previous
language models would be interesting as
training data for new language models I
don't know if it will work I think my
guess just like somebody will like
figure this out because incentives are
definitely there because here we go this
is just like the easiest way for us to
like acquire more data and I guess
companies will look into this
um and personally probably not excited
about it I was like ah AI systems
feeding into AI systems I don't know I
think this is like how failure could
look like you know you just have like
these Loops of AI systems you have like
barely an idea where it did go wrong
right and we have like this two layered
black boxes well congrats you know we
make it even harder to understand
everything so I guess it would
definitely go for this yeah trying to
use this synthetic data to something
you're just like trying to make it up
but also just like maybe you have like I
mean I think maybe an example is like
actually this this llama model which
came out of matter and then Stanford
made a pack out of it right and I think
if I understand it correctly correctly
they like fine tune unit based on
feedback from chatubity there we go or
with an example you don't need human
labor anymore you can skip your Amazon
turacus you just use chatibility it's
way cheaper turns out it was like cheap
pretty good and this model is like
performing really well so I expected at
least for fine tuning it will be useful
but I think we should like really be
conscious there and just like again
black boxes feeding two black boxes I
think it's not an ideal scheme from My
Lens who wants to understand these
systems and make sure they're actually
yeah well understood what about trading
off algorithmic progress against the
data or compute so so imagine if we had
optimal algorithms how much would this
matter for example I saw a deepmind
recently made an advance in algorithmic
matrix multiplication I believe which is
kind of a core process of machine
learning how much does this matter could
this make say compute less relevant
because algorithms would be so efficient
that they would need less compute to run
there there's definitely history I think
it's just like I mean if we go back to
the eye trainer algorithms is one thing
and the question like well how
algorithmic efficiency developed over
time the promises I think it's really
hard to measure and the best ways of
measuring it is right now we look at the
Benchmark which we use in this case um
people used imagenet and looked and it's
like well how much compute do I need to
achieve the capability X on this
Benchmark over time and Bobby
historically seen there the compute used
is halfing I think every nine to one
year right so like in a year from now I
can shift the same capability right now
for half of the compute of the previous
system which achieves its capability
that's a big deal right but again
compute Trends have been like a bit
faster right because eventually it's not
about achieving capability X it's about
like you want to keep on pushing it
Frontier right I think just like every
percentage point of accuracy every
percentage point of like better
capabilities is actually useful because
we're now entering this new error where
we're actually trying to make money out
of these systems and sometimes single
digit percent points just matter there's
just the difference between we all have
autonomous cars or we don't have any
autonomous cars right now but it's like
yep we have like really high standards
for these kinds of systems so
algorithmic efficiency definitely
reduces the computer use the question is
like where do we continue pushing our AI
systems and historical we've seen just
like bigger and bigger systems and then
you have like better gains due to
algorithmic efficiency but also due to
because we just throw more computed the
problem more data okay let's let's you
have this graph with different eras of
compute usage in machine Learning
Systems
um where starting with the pre-deep
learning era and then the Deep learning
and then large scale systems who could
try to describe this graph for us what
what's the key lessons from this yeah so
this is coming from our paper as a three
errors of machine of compute usage and
machine learning or something along
these lines
um so like the key thing is what we
looked at like we looked at training
compute which we've just discussed and
trying to figure out like how this has
been developing over time and before the
time we mean I think we started in 1958
or something like when like the first
advantage of AI has been happening and
this is what we call the pre-deep
Learning area the Deep learning area
roughly emerged in 2010 to 2012. and
within this area we roughly see the
training compute is doubling every two
years
this reminds of us another law which
might a lot of people might know which
is called muslaw
um Muslim exactly describes the trans uh
transistor density on ships but I think
in this case we can just roughly say
well the price performance doubles every
two years you know every two years you
get a chip which is you know twice as
good for the same price this basically
means in this pre-deep learning area
people just always spend like a constant
Budget on on training these systems you
know like maybe this constant budget was
just like yep the CPU the processor
which was like right at this desk of
this researcher but at some point in
2010 2012 the Deep learning area emerged
right famously with LX in it maybe with
our systems before they did one new
thing they use gpus Graphics processing
units which are really really good at
computation of parallel problems at
matrix multiplication right which is the
key thing which we do for our training
these AI systems and with this error we
basically see like wow people are
starting building bigger and bigger
systems deeper systems right deep
learning that's what we do here and to
compute growth just like Skyrocket right
and I think there's like it's really
important it's like doubling every six
months right from 2010 to 2012. that's a
big deal right if you double something
for six months this cannot go on forever
let's talk about this question of
whether this can go on because so far
we've talked about you know companies
now reaching three nanometers uh which
is extremely tiny probably close to the
physical limits uh you tell me and what
what does this mean uh are we running
out of a possibility to create denser
computer chips yeah let's take a step in
just like well computers doubling every
six months can this go on forever so
what I've just I think yeah when we do
when we say like we spent more compute
on these systems what are the factors
which enable us to spend more compute on
these systems well it looks like
computers get better over time how much
better do they get over time I think
moose law says they're double every two
years
um recent investigation by my colleagues
Tamaya and Marios looked at the price
performance of gpus in a roughly found
well the price performance doubles every
2.5 years right so every 2.5 years you
get double the amount of floating Point
operations for the same cost
when compute then doubles every six
months this basically means we just
spend more money that's what we do right
we spend more money on the system than
it looks like people did it because it
paid off of the capabilities there are
limits to how much money we can spend if
something doubles like every six months
so if you crunchy numbers and you
roughly assume like hey it's doubling
every six months and price performance
half like every 2.5 years so this buys
you more over time at some point you hit
like you spent one percent of the US GDP
or you spend like similar amounts as the
Apollo project on these kinds of
training systems is this likely I don't
know it depends what the economic return
is of these systems are people actually
incentivized to do this
um it depends if you actually have so
much compute out there you know do we
have data centers actually big enough
that you just like can't burn so much
money it's not like if I wave with money
immediately compute the peers maybe a
couple of years later it appears if I
wave with the money and as you said well
I've just been saying what way price
performance
um has been like halfing every 2.5 years
or like doubling every 2.5 years
we just continue right and and now we
get into the weeds we're just like every
electric engineering hates you photos
I'm like well will Moore's Law continue
is this actually true I'm just like man
I don't care about Moore's Law I care
about just like price performance will
it continue
um my rough guess is just like yeah
there are road maps out there I think
when I probably at least find for
another five years of making transistor
smaller you're right at some point we we
hit like new barriers just like how
small they can these transistors make
but quick to us you're like human
intuitivity it's been great you've just
like continue doing this we throw
exponential money out at this but we
also get exponential more gains so I
guess there is more to to do there but
even even if moose law stops I think
it's like an important concept to
understand is right now we have this
really short on these Cycles people want
new iPhone every year right every year
we want the new processor so your r d
spending for these chips is immense If
instead we have like longer r d Cycles
this means we spend more money of
developing this we might have better
economies of scale so while your
performance per chip stays the same you
can sell the same chip over five years
compared to usually one year so we might
see better come to your scale so the
performance stays the same but the price
might drop which then eventually meets
the price performance it might continue
to yeah go up over time that you just
get more for your money
um but yeah key question for people to
figure out what's going on there really
hard question because you're just trying
to forecast basically yeah just on the
future of humanity the future of
computing and historically I mean most
law was pretty good at this I don't know
about the other forecasts on this do you
think there's some other Paradigm coming
after this this continual punt or
continual attempt to try to squeeze more
and more transistors onto a chip do you
think there's some you know some Quantum
phenomena or some 3D Computing or is
there anything you could see as an
interesting uh heir to to the present
Paradigm yeah I'm guess there will be
like in the beginning we'll have like
hybrid approaches or something right he
was like well our chips you know like
they're like we're hitting the limit of
small we can make but maybe can stick
them or you can just like put them all
together like what Apple did with M1
Ultra it's like well
we only can make a chip this big but
what if we just put them next to each
other with like a high performance
interconnect or like what amd's company
is like well we chips only get this code
but let's just put four next to each
other and like trying to connect them so
like there's like a bunch of hybrid
mechanisms like how you're trying to
work your way around this right putting
more chips next to each other doesn't
sound to me like the same kind of
progress as making transistors smaller
and fitting more of them on a chip that
seems right it's definitely it's
definitely a different different out of
progress there but like I think what I'm
saying is like yeah and they're like
different ways around this and there's
like one way how you use hybrid
techniques or like new techniques and
they always like people to start
thinking about completely new Computing
paradigms right like in the beginning we
had like those big relays and then
eventually moved to integrated circuits
and while integrated circuits have been
powering us for like the last 60 years
or something or like 80 or something
the question's like what's next Yeah you
mentioned Quantum Computing I'm not
expert on this whenever I talk to people
like probably it's overhyped as
everything
um and even like I think it's diff is
trying to solve different problems there
but I'm guessing the wrong person to
talk there what else is out there
there's something like neuromorphic
Computing like more like analog
Computing is brain inspired Computing I
expect us to make like more progress
there and this is particularly
interesting when you think about AI
cases my rough guess right now is like
at least the things which I've seen it's
pretty interesting for inference but not
for training systems yet and I also
don't know my other thing is like this
is still process on Silicon I just don't
know if you need Cutting Edge ships
right
um I would rather call it like to some
degree it's like design Innovation you
produce different types of chips but
it's still silicon chips and other
things which are the optical Computing I
have no clue about Optical Computing if
this is promising or not people will
like figure this out over time and at
some point it might become cost
competitive
I'm pretty bullish that it's not going
to be happening in the next eight to ten
years or something but then ask me again
and we can see where we are so to what
extent if we're trying to predict what's
going to happen with AI progress based
on compute how much should we take into
account these kind of wild cards or or
Black Swan events or whatever you want
to call it where suddenly perhaps we get
a much more intense progress in compute
based on something like you know Optical
Computing or Quantum Computing or
something that that an advance that we
hadn't anticipated an advanced that's
not part of the trend line that we're
extrapolating we should take an account
I would like put relatively low
probability on this it's it's not like
the case nobody is trying right now to
just build a processor right there's
money to be made if you figure out like
something better than what tsmc is doing
and just to replace this billion dollar
industry with something cheaper which
you can build in your garage here we go
I think you just you just won the
lottery congrats I think a bunch of
people are trying this the same goes for
algorithmic Innovation everything around
computation eventually I think a bunch
of stuff just boils down to just like
this this exponential growth or like
some kind of growth maybe I'm just the
economist you're like yep it's always
three percent GDP growth you know that's
that's always the thing that's always
what's been happening I was like yep
it's always Muslim it's just like this
the self fulfilling
um thing which you're like
um trying to do so do I put a lot of
probabilities on these kinds of events
most of the time not because I care
about like price performance you might
tell me like well it's not going to be a
flop in the future it might be something
else it might be light bending whatever
I was like yeah it might be the case but
eventually what like I care about the
output or something right that's the
thing we we gotta look out for there I'm
probably compared if you look at the eye
Trend like do I expect like major
breakthroughs and like better Computing
performance probably not do I expect
major breakthroughs for algorithms yeah
I have like a higher probability there
because we have systems like our brain
rooms like there there is some good
algorithm out there you know it's like
it's running here right now and it's
pretty energy efficient it's more energy
efficient than gpd4 so I'm like there is
something out there right it's
physically possible there there I have
some proofs I have like higher
probability that these kinds of things
might be happening tell us the
difference between AI timeline
forecasting and AI takeoff speeds
um the timelines are trying to usually I
mean sometimes people just say one year
but we're trying to figure out like the
time and point when transformative AI
AGI whatever you want to Define is
emerging so it's a point in time and
usually people try to put like uh
probabilities on this right there's like
some kind of normal distribution around
this or some kind of distribution around
it whereas takeoff speeds is a Time
duration where people are asking like
how long does it take to go from A to B
and then we already start getting to the
weeds how do you define eventually A to
B one way how to go about this is just
like what a recent report by Tom
Davidson trying to do is they think
about just like when can we automate
most of human labor in the world like
most cognitive tasks or something it's
like well the takeoff is and I'm not
sure if it's exactly these numbers but
something like from 20 to 100 of like
having all human cognitive or like I
think all human labor
um eventually automated other people
think about takeoff differently others
are just like well takeoff is the thing
from the first artificial general
intelligence defined by some metrics to
the point where this thing is going to
take over the world
something along these lines so like take
off just obviously consideration from A
to B and what these A's and B's are
everybody has like different ideas there
and I think all of them are like
somewhat useful but all of these models
end up looking different and some of
these models are more attractable some
of the models are just way harder yeah
we could have two people with the same
AI timelines say that they predict AGI
by 2050 but different AI takeoff speed
predictions say that one person predicts
that we will have a slow take on say
that we will have
progress beginning in the 2030s and and
being steady all the way up to 2050 or
another person predicting that we will
have uh much slower progress until
2048 from which we will have extreme uh
extreme progress so that's that's kind
of the the difference we have there is
there anything to learn from studying
compute specifically about takeoff
speeds and here I'm I'm thinking for
example this is just my kind of
uneducated guess that if we know
something about the compute how
computers is produced and what how much
compute is available this puts an a
limit to how fast a takeoff we could
have do you think there's something to
that absolutely I think there's
something to it right we just like look
at compute just like what does it matter
for takeoff
um we might have discussed a bit of
scale like maybe we can go back to the
bioencres model you might be saying well
takeoff is from the childhood Milestone
to the evolution Milestone right because
they both describe the amount of Labor
you can automate or something then both
of them are defined by compute here we
go compute is useful I think where it's
more interesting to just like actually
look at a computer as a limiting factor
for takeoff right we need to deploy
these systems we need to train more
systems so do we actually have enough
compute for this right A lot of people
are just like well if current threats
continue and we have like another 10
years of of this progress we use this
much compute and asking like well do we
actually have so much compute like how
much ships does tsmc actually producing
so the production capabilities of like
Fabs how much chips are going to be out
there just just meta for these types of
questions it also just matters like what
about other things like at the moment is
something it's like mostly producing
like chips for MacBooks for smartphones
and AI chips like just under a small
minority of these chips will AI be
economically important enough will
people believe this that they actually
re-steer and produce less smartphones
and Moya accelerators or will you just
build more Fabs and there are limits to
this right if like the US is trying to
do build perhaps right now it just takes
a long time and it just really really
hard and just costs a lot of money and
all these kinds of things eventually can
then inform form how do you feel about
takeoff and just like compute being a
bottleneck there right and not too
important like important geopolitical
events right if you don't have access to
compute or if you think about tsmc which
is sitting in Taiwan and there's a China
Taiwan Invasion this plays in a really
important role just like how many eye
chips are out there are they accessible
and distant feeds into just like are we
actually doing these large training runs
are we actually running enough AI models
so we have like some some yeah certain
percentages of the economy being
automated perhaps a very fast takeoff
would require something that we haven't
seen before in terms of algorithmic
efficiency for it to overcome this this
bottleneck of of compute which we talked
about what we can learn from trying to
forecast AI progress because it might
seem like a a sort of you know whether
whether we have transformative AI by
2050 or 2055. I don't know how much that
matters but you talked about how we can
how how there are important insights to
be gained from studying from from trying
to forecast Ai and the thing you've
landed on is just the importance of
compute so perhaps you could here
introduce this notion of compute
governance that you've landed on yeah I
mean as you just said like computer is
one of these inputs and like well looks
like an important input
um what can we do
um what is my definition of compute
governance so like when we go back to
this air production function we have
like these inputs we have algorithm
State and compute and my claim is well
if I if I wiggle this compute node I can
I can do something about like AI down
here like the deployment of AI systems
the training of AI systems eventually
also this being used in a beneficial way
that's like that's a rough claim that's
what I describe as compute governance
what the outcomes are there are various
different things you can eventually
achieve of this that's what I'm trying
to figure out fantastic